these walls in the studio here could
shock the dick jokes they would tell
shut up walls we recorded at midnight
here on Sunset Las Palmas is legendary
stage 2 this is where I Love Lucy was
filmed the first couple comedian you've
all been here multiple times that's why
you're here we had a lot of our favorite
comics on near the end of the run I want
you to tell us some of the things that
have been overheard backstage here at
@midnight in 60 seconds and begin
Paul I mean why couldn't the show just
go on but someone else hosted yeah I've
heard that too I've heard that too
fine Flula hey suck it losers I'm
converting my points to Bitcoin oh then
I don't know what show Comedy Central
replaced this with but it definitely
won't be hosted by a woman yeah follow
Duncan hey do you also get paid in hard
bucks said black we need something to
prop that Benton's eyes open by Loula I
played your game Hardwick now release my
family
not until to show